I understand you are a poet and you
enjoy poetry is there a poem by a poet
that you admire that describes your life
is an actor hmm Oh whether it's struggle
whether it's fun whether it's
interesting fascinating not a poem about
acting but we're in general I myself the
Walt Whitman poem which is just about
America and about all the different
elements like I think that's a poem that
I really related to because he tried to
see everything he tried to see the
animals you saw the plans he saw the
human body he saw the politician he saw
the all the different workers in the
city in saw the city's he saw the planes
you saw the different parts of America
he saw it was the poet's job to bring
all these different elements both the
physical and the spiritual the emotional
the personal the public and bring them
all together and express the meaning of
those and like the essence of those and
our perception of those and it was his
job to communicate that so I think he
was trying to be aware of everything and
how it all relates and so I think that
resonated with me as an actor because he
got to be aware of it all at least try
to you won't know everything if you
think that then you're gonna stop
progressing but you always got to try
you know when he say something like talk
about how he's at the Opera House he
says that like the I am not quoting
directly but the voice of the soprano
like brings me convulsions like the
climax of my love grip look and I was
like damn and that guy that's a cool way
of looking at the world that guy so in
the end of opera and he's just so into
the the the the product of this woman
and the writing in the and the the house
at all these people are watching it in
that guy literally is coming on life why
Walt Whitman though like it is are there
other poems what is it about his being
so aware like this watcher uh is he also
an outsider but he was yeah for sure I
mean he used free verse and there's so
much more wild and loose and not as
tight and concise as the British poetry
even the American poets ended the right
in the bridge tradition you know like
there would be a certain number of beats
for every line and make their be rhyming
and you know you had a very specific
point that you had to make in a very
kind of like grounded and controlled
framework and Walt Whitman just cut it
loose so he made his own meter and he
made his own verse lines and he just
like through every good sounding word in
there he could find this is just
something shaggy an untamed about his
poems that I love something wild and
control which is like America at that
time like this he's a product of all
like these people that going out west
and these people like making all these
new factories like people cutting down
trees at North like all these people
just scrambling like make something out
of this land and you know he he was he
saw the Civil War it so the nation
nearly tear itself apart he saw all
these different people he's Irish people
in French people and English people and
black people in Native Americans and and
so there's just he's just wildly even
says something like I shake my wild
locks at the Sun and and yeah he was his
poetry was so sexual to a lot of it
which shocked and offended many many
people is that what you want to play a
character that's very raw that's very
sort of on taste some of them yeah I
mean there's a lot of different
characters I want to play not just
outsiders but right I'd love to play a
character like that it sucks there was a
actually a play in New York that I
wanted to audition for so badly but it
was Walt Whitman in his 30s oh I was too
young I think it was called what was it
it was a it was like Emily Dickinson
paranormal investigator just about a
version of Emily Dickinson that was a
paranormal investigator and their
version of Walt Whitman it said think of
like a young dracula someone who was
willing to do anything to get what he
wants and he sells the soul and I was
like damn I wish I could play that
version of Walt Whitman
you